У лютому 2001 року Папа Римський Іван Павло Другий
вручив йому червоний кардинальський капелюх.
17 років потому від блиску того дня мало що залишилося.
Теодор Маккеррік - колишній архієпископ Вашингтона
та один з найвідоміших лідерів Католицької церкви - перший кардинал,
який пішов з посади через сексуальні зловживання.
Тож, у Ватикана чималі проблеми.
Слідчі американського штату Пенсильванія звинувачують  загалом 300 священників
у сексуальних злочинах.
Ідеться про тисячу жертв їхніх домагань.
Папа Франциск засудив це в листі.
Жертви повинні знати, що Папа на їхньому боці.
Він хоче, щоб церква до них прислухалася,
щоб запобігти у майбутньому цьому трагічному жахіттю,
яке зруйнувало так багато життів невинних людей.
У різних куточках світу католицька церква
спливає на перших шпальтах газет через сексуальні скандали.
Багато таких випадків намагаються якомога довше приховувати.
У липні пішов з посади австралійський архієпископ Філіп Вілсон.
Його звинуватили у тому, що він, імовірно,
приховував випадки сексуального насильства з боку одного зі священників.
У Чілі священннику Фернандо Карадімі закидають сексуальне насильство
над дітьми, що продовжувалося десятиліттями.
Він вважався одним з найважливіших церковних осіб країни.
У всій країні нині розслідують 160 випадків насильства.
У Німеччині також спливли сотні випадків зловживань.
Один з найкричущіших - 550 хлопчиків з церковного хору у Регенбургу
у різні роки стали жертвами сексуального насильства.
Від Папи Римського очікують тепер рішучих дій,
аби покласти край сексуальним зловживанням у католицькій церкві.